I would say that I could say looking
back hindsight is 20 20. I'll be like ah
you missed that yeah you missed that oh
you missed that didn't you but because
there's a whole thing of when you're in
a relationship you're just in one and
people from the outside can see it which
is very interesting about love people
from the outside can say yeah I saw some
things and you're like no I love them
I'm cool everything's fine and that's
what and the thing is that's what
essentially what people are supposed to
do in relationships are not supposed to
allow people from the outside into there
I don't believe in allowing outside
people into your relationship
I don't believe that because I believe
that's one of the best ways for a
relationship to break down
so when you're in the relationship I get
why people say oh we were just in it and
it was happening and I didn't listen to
anybody else because I am I am a firm
believer that if I'm with you and you're
with me we should only listen to each
other because we are the ones in the
relationship no one else is in it it's
just us so